welcome to this video playing mando cars
it's Finn it's Willa something like that
Columbia yeah I often get the region
right but the specific flickr often is a
problem okay as a measure variation and
let's see what line is opting for to 290
rate at night a 6 this is quite uncommon
let's see you have in the Benoni the
night Wow always amazed how quickly they
dish out some moves that once in a while
and this is really not a great setup
okay I'll try to get in G 493 and of
course I'm not going to allow b5 quickly
ok so he might be able to play be five
yeah but ok on be five hours who can
play a five and then the queenside
remains a closed not with the bishop
this is a last night be five ok so in
this position him let's let's let's
let's let's do with this in a slow slow
fashion not not be too hasty
yeah this is the type of position where
you if you need to get if you are able
to get the Queen's off you're almost
winning and okay he's going into the
desperation mode this is um yeah of
course it incorrect sacrifice but it's
blitz chess so let's see what happens we
had to put the bishop yeah I go all the
way back yeah I five if i take it
probably place you for something like
that so not not great I wonder about age
three and this is probably to weakening
okay let's just cancel short yeah it's
always it's a little bit tricky i mean
like has some some some active pieces
okay
Green g2 he maybe has f3 button I've
Queen g3 okay I want to prepare native
to I can then then he can take and play
93
yeah it's always easy if you're lost
from the front from the beginning you
can just dash out some moves you lost
anyway so you can play play quickly and
don't get really care about if it's good
or not um okay I hope that I can play
that move don't want to fall too far
behind on the clock and you can take one
to two now I cannot the idea my idea was
Rukia 3 9 p-2 covering d3 so I was
hoping that this actually wins yeah
that's always some a bit scary those
desperation attacks but I don't don't
see at the moment how it's going to like
it not really take on d 2 okay a vet
Bishop f 8 22 Bishop age six and trying
to use the bishop it's probably not
enough but yeah this is a strong i guess
so here no go here this pattern
controlling you one
so he's threatening on edge too if i go
here Queen h2 king of one's there made
night III check not easy it takes I can
go to g2 not terribly dangerous how to
how to play that maybe this one hmm I
had still a good turkey
it seems that first I still can play
that teenage talking everyone and he
doesn't even have a check so let's hope
that check this is a wooden I didn't see
that at all wow wow wow stone yeah it's
okay for me it's okay but check I had
completely forgotten about the whole
possibility and now Queen g1 made would
be terribly embarrassing so let's go
here and now he doesn't have a square
for the Queen I think the rook is
protecting f2 black resigned hm yeah ah
this is always important to really win
those kind of games where they're simply
sacrificing correctly and and well it
did this said this position black is
basically a strategically busted he
needs to do something drastic oh I'm
something something extreme maybe from
practical point of view this is even
okay but um yeah well computer just
takes at five and says it's nothing but
okay I cannot do that and the round he
really has something it's it's it's
dangerous do not sure maybe here 93 is
winning for Black Moon
hmm yeah it was dangerous it was
dangerous after that I think I'm winning
check check check yeah after that I was
winning yeah maybe I should have played
a bit more cautiously to not even allow
this takes on g4 I mean it's it's not
really good but maybe I should have done
something to prevent it here if I don't
play the Queen at the moment let's say I
play that move for for example then I've
keep this protected and this is just an
excellent position like it's um I just
need to get the Queen's off then I have
an excellent play on the queenside I
have to be 6 as the entry square and I
always have this possible p sacrifice on
c5 to get the passes so very very
dangerous position for black but the way
you played that that God really tricky
and you have the computers of course
very cool about that he just takes it
just takes it and no but should be too
okay and this is this I could have
played actually this is not so difficult
yeah I am I understand this is a very
tricky now it's hanging here and um yeah
something like that doesn't feel like
enough still it's tricky and let's look
f3 and whatever yeah I should have
probably prevented the whole sacrifice
all together this was a tricky position
entrance alright thanks for watching